hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the noon chess classic it's magnus
carlson versus hikaru nakamura and sorry
about no videos for the past few days
but
we kind of had to relocate uh very
suddenly but
we're gonna discuss that you know in a
live stream i'm planning to have one
uh at maybe even tomorrow so uh you know
you guys can ask some questions if you
guys are interested in anything
i could have recorded some videos maybe
yesterday or you know but
i only got to the couch here uh today
like an hour ago i'm still pretty pretty
sweaty from all that
but i knew you guys wouldn't want any
videos without meadow chilling in the
background so you know i had to make the
necessary adjustments
so this is the first game that we're
showing and since i've just moved
pretty much all of my equipment i still
don't know if i've plugged in everything
correctly so sorry if
not everything is fully operational uh
hopefully that will get
you know fixed with maybe the the second
or the third video
but that being said let's check it out
and we're going to discuss the details
uh at some other point in time but
magnus
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by hikaru
uh c6 with e6 knight to c3 and now
bishop to b4 of course going for the
nimzo indian defense which is
a very nice attempt always with black to
you know play for for more than a draw
it's a very sharp opening
and here uh over the course of time like
e3 the traditional line and queen to c2
the classical line
have been the most popular and this is
what magnus goes for he goes queen to c2
goes for the classical variation
uh we have castles by black and now a3
challenging black's strong dark square
bishop we have captures here and now
queen captures there are some games
where b captures was played but
um very very few queen captures is the
main idea here
and now black strikes in the center with
d5 and black wants to get
uh well black basically wants the
capture on c4 get the queen on c4 and
then use the queen on c4 as a tempo so
he can play v6 and bishop to a6 with the
attack on the queen and
that's what black uses in this line to
kind of develop all of his pieces
so here bishop the g 5 by magnus and not
d
captures on c4 as planned we have queen
captures and
now b6 preparing the the said move but
it's uh
it's not a problem for white this has
been played many times
and while you could go for something
like rook to c1 to go after the c7 pawn
then white can just go
h6 and they for example captures
captures uh you still can't capture on
c7 because the d4 pawn will be hanging
and this is perfectly fine for black
even even better
so instead rook to d1 this is the main
move here
and now bishop to a6 as planned so queen
to a4 now preventing the
knight from being developed because the
bishop would hang and
h6 asking do you want to capture which
would only help me develop
or do you want to go back so here bishop
to h4 this is best
and queen to e7 for the moment uh
keeping this pin because you can't
really move the queen anywhere else then
you allow black white to open up your
king side
so knight to f3 white still needs to
finish development because his king is
still in the center of the board we have
rook to d8
and now comes e3 offering the trade of
light square bishops
uh we have bishop captures and now rook
capture so now white will not be able to
castle
or rather will not be able to castle in
a traditional way but of course you will
be able to
at the castle artificially which is what
magnus is going for
so here we have c5 this is always
black's plan pretty much in in such
lines we have d
captures on c5 rook captures sunday one
and now this position has been reached i
think like maybe
15 times maybe 13 i don't know uh
something something like that
and the queen characters on d1 is the
move that has always been played here
and
interestingly hikaru had it against
shakhtar mamidyarov mamiyara of course
also captured with the queen here
i was in norway chess in 2018 and the
the game ended in the draw but here
magnus prepared something special he
played king captures on d1
this has never been played and it is now
as of move 16 that we have a completely
new game so let's see what magnus
uh will do with his king on d1
uh but you know it's a new move so very
very exciting so hikaru immediately
strikes with the g5 he wants to unpin
here now the both the queen and knight
are
ready to move bishop to g3 and now
queen catches on c5 you didn't want to
do this uh
before because then you allow white to
open up your king side
king to d2 now this is uh carlson's plan
now he wants to bring the rook into the
game and artificially castle
so knight b to d7 you still need to
bring your other pieces into the game
very principled idea uh and now comes
rook the c1 attacking the queen
queen d5 check and now king the e2
and here he car went knight to c5 and
this is kind of the
uh the moment i think why everyone plays
queen captures on d1 in that position
instead of king captures because here
uh it seems that the g4 is best but i
guess uh you know
it's not winning for black or anything
it just that black might get some sort
of an edge here maybe
and then for example knight the e1 and
then after rook the d8 it's
similar like what happened in the game
but then if white tries to exchange
queens for example with queen to c4 then
you freed up the g5 square for your
queen
and then you can continue pushing
because nothing is really you know wrong
with black's position you can
just you know play play whatever you
want but okay
uh hikar went without us he played
knight to c5 right away but now magnus
says queen to c4 and now the queen
doesn't really have
all that uh many many good squares uh
queen offer is uh
uh on the board if you try something
like queen to a
f5 then you allow certain jumps like
knight to d4 with an attack on the queen
and uh it's a it's a a rapid game you
don't really have all that much time
uh to try this uh i still have c
so sorry about that uh as i've been
covering the candidates tournaments let
me just
quickly fix that i know you guys are
always weirded out by that so just give
me a second here
there we go all right uh
all right there we go nice
all right so we've we've covered that
and uh
now instead of that after queen to c4 we
have rook to d8 by hikaru and
now comes queen captures and d5 magnus
trades here and now it doesn't matter
that his king is in the center of the
board
uh in fact it is more than welcome uh
let me just uh
fix something really quickly uh uh as
um as i'm showing the game uh wow sorry
about that
as i'm showing the game i'm realizing
things that i've forgotten as i haven't
recorded for
for the past three days but okay queen
c4 we have rook to d8 magnus traits
captures
and now knight captures on d5 we have
knight to d4
uh and now comes a5 so uh what do you
play here
uh we rook the c4 by magnus and now rook
to d7 we have f3 taking away all of
these squares from hikaru's knights
and now uh we have a4 that's a very nice
idea at some point if this knight moves
you will always have the b3 square for
your knight and
well you just keep the white b2 pawn
in there so it's a backwards pawn for
the rest of the game it could be a very
very big weakness so here we have knight
to b5 by magnus and
now comes f6 by hikar we have e4 chasing
away this knight
and now knight back to e7 and here
magnus throws in
bishop to c7 bishop to d6 is also very
nice
puts pressure on both this knight so the
rook doesn't really
have any uh any squares to go to uh and
also you are just threatening to win a
pawn with bishop captures but magnus
decides to go for this pawn instead
uh and it's very interesting how kikaru
uh hikaru
uh defends it he goes knight the g6
first now
uh you can't really go after the pawn
right away
uh because if you go for example
uh bishop captures here then knight to
f4 check
and this is now very ugly because this
pawn is hanging and if you go
defended with sun like king to f2 then
you allow rook to d2 then this pawn
falls and it's just a
very very ugly position so magnus has to
play g3 first
take away the f4 square from hikaru's
knight and now
knight to e5 again the rook is under
attack and now instead of going for this
pawn so that's why maybe bishop to d6
was better now magnus
decides to trade on e5 so we have
characters captures
and knight back to c3 we have knight to
b3
finally getting to that square uh that
we discussed
uh and now comes knight captures on a4
grabbing that pawn
and now b5 so you don't win a piece
because there's always rook to c8
check king to f7 and now knight to c
uh sorry uh knight to c5 offering a
trade of knights
uh we have rook to d2 with check king to
e3
and now of course you defend the knight
with rook captures and b2 this is how he
car
grabs the pawn rook the c7 with check
king the e8 and now knight captures on
e6 and now the black king isn't in a in
a great position but
uh the black rook on the other hand is
uh well
ready to gobble up a lot of pawns here
so rook captures on h2
we have rook to b7 going after the b5
pawn and
now knight to c1 uh magnus strikes here
with
f4 uh and hikaru trades here uh
of course you can't you have to play f4
f4 is a must
move here if you try something like rook
captures on b5 rook 32 is checkmate so
you have to
you know take care of stuff like that so
instead we have f4
and now g captures on f4 we have g
captures on f4 and now
rook the h3 with check going after the
a3 pawn
king to d2 attacking the knight now
comes knight b3 check
king to c2 so now the knight is in the
way
uh the pawn cannot be captured and
knight the a5 now attacking carlson's
rook
rook captures on b5 and now knight to c4
uh so what do you do here uh we rook the
b4 again chasing back at the knight and
now knight to e3 check king d2
uh and now e captures an f4 so what do
you play here here uh we have a4
starting to push this uh this past pawn
uh you could go
after the the pawn here but if you play
knight captures on f4 then there's
knight to f1
with check and if king to e1 for example
you can go rook
captures on a3 and now the problem is if
the king captures knight
then just check and you win back tonight
and it's an instant draw
so magnus starts pushing the pass pawn
and
now comes knight to g2 we have e5
and now uh you see what magnus is trying
to do he's trying to create a mating net
by using the knight and the pawn you'll
see what what uh
what his plan is but he's extremely low
on the clock he has
30 seconds on the clock whereas he car
has almost three minutes on the clock
so here we have f3 uh hikaru is also
very close to queening his pawn and now
knight the g7 with check king to f8 and
this king to f8
is uh not the the most precise way king
to f7 is better because you simply take
away
this square from the pawn he cover
played king to f8 and this allowed
magnus this instant
knight to f5 and this is now a problem
uh because
uh here the knight is covering these two
squares if you push the pawn
here then the pawn covers this square
and the king will not be able to escape
you will get
checkmated so here there is only one
move that saves hikaru so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this the only move hikaru has not to
lose this game
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not doing anything weird like rook to h5
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f2
this is how you save the game and now
the problem is well uh
of course if you go after the knight
then uh just rook the b8
check i know you guys are wondering
about this king f7 and now e6 this is
the problem and now if you capture it
then you lose the rook
and if you don't capture it doesn't
really matter then we just give up the
knight
just e7 the pawn is nicely guarded by
the knight and
white is just queening there's nothing
black can do here so hikaru finds it he
plays f2 he spends a minute and a half
here
so he also got very low on time magnus
played e6 now threatening checkmate but
now hikaru finds the move
of course not f1 queen because then this
is checkmate
rook to d3 with check that's the good
stuff because now if you capture it
then uh f1 queen uh this comes with
check and now magnus is lost
so after rook d3 check king to e2 was
played
and now of course f1 queen he car
replaced
everything perfectly king captures and
now rook f3 check
going after the knight here we have
captures captures and now
rook to b5 hoping for a rook trade then
of course the pawn
uh king and pawn end game would be
winning but of course just rook to f4
magnus plays rook to a5 you want to have
your rook behind the pass pawn but in
front of it
is also kind of good so here king e7
going after the pawn and rook a6
defending both pawns but now
h5 hikaru also starts pushing his past
pawn
we have a5 and now rook to a4 so the
problem uh for magnus is that he is up
upon but his king is not
in this game at all so here uh we have
king to h3
now comes h4 hikaru nicely defends that
pawn as well
uh we have rook to a8 magnus prepares to
push the pawn but now just king captures
on e6 now the material is equal
we have e6 king to d7 a7 and now king to
c7 hikaru is going after the pawn
uh we have rooked the h8 that's not an
h8
rook to h8 and now of course comes rook
captures on a7 magnus
uh delivers check he will pick up the
rook but it's not a problem just
captures captures and captures
and it was in this position that uh of
course the game ended in a draw due to
insufficient material
which some of you uh probably caught a
glimpse of because i accidentally showed
the disposition
a few minutes ago so sorry about that uh
but uh yeah
it will take me a few videos to get back
into the uh you know
into the mood uh but yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it sorry
about no videos for the last three days
but we really had a
madness with all of the moving and
everything but
uh i hope everything is nicely set up i
will
uh be improving the background uh with
every video so i really
you know tried my best to get everything
done uh until the finals but
you know it was not easy uh it's
impossible to you know just move stuff
from one place to another not impossible
but it's you know not not very simple
uh and i knew you guys would not
tolerate if uh if
meadows couch was not you know ready for
him so so he can just
chill uh but also i've acquired this
very nice new camera i still i i'm still
not going to use it i'm going to use it
for some ideas
uh for example you can see here that
it's although it's very
very crisp it's not a pretty sight i
know but it's you know the the quality
is
uh you know pretty amazing this is
actually mean 4k
so uh if you guys ever wondered what i
look like in 4k
this is me uh but yeah for some
announcements and uh you know for
something that i will be talking about
maybe discussing that
is not directly related to the current
situation on the board
i might be using uh uh this uh this uh
this camera as well
uh so yeah uh like i said that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it really uh
magnus did prepare with that king to d1
move but hikaru
you know uh did everything uh everything
precisely and
he he probably could have seized a
better position at some points but in
the end he he found that he only moved
that f2 move that
ensured him a draw and after that it was
just you know and he didn't take him a
lot this fd movie
it took him like a minute and maybe a
minute and a half and you know uh
because this is scary
i mean uh you know people people would
uh
a lot of people would lose here finding
f2 here is very very
very very nice but yeah once again hope
you guys enjoyed it
sorry about no videos for the past three
days but we are now
back back at it uh so uh
hope you guys enjoyed it once again uh i
would like to thank uh andre mitrochin
uh david meininger uh albert yazer
uh dan madge and ishmael rivera for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the new chess
classic checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
you know do comment if everything is
okay with the sound with the setup you
know i i
i'm here to you know to learn uh see you
soon